Well, let's see. Again, we have our right triangle, which we love so much.
We have an adjacent side to our angle and a hypotenuse.
Adjacent and hypotenuse SOH-CAH-TOA--CAH. Cosine and adjacent over hypotenuse.
Okay, the cosine of that angle α is equal to the adjacent side, 400,000,
over this L. Okay. Well, let's solve for L.
We find that L = 400,000 divided by the cosine α, which we said was 89.853 degrees.
This gives an answer of about 156,000,000 km.
Boy, that's a lot of zeros.
Take a second to pat yourself on the back.
You can now calculate astronomical sizes and distances--the sun, the earth, the moon,
the distance from the earth to the sun and the earth to the moon.
These are all things that you now know how to calculate. That's very impressive.